all right hey everybody we're here for
night
four four of four uh of the democratic
national
convention we are going to be seeing joe
biden officially accept the nomination
today we're going to hear his speech
there maybe will be memes there maybe
will be
all sorts of different things so i'm
glad you're with me on this fourth of
four consecutive nights
boy it has been a long week but it is
coming to a close
today and starting at the top
of the hour let's look at what's on the
calendar today in addition to
joe biden we will be hearing from
senator cory booker
pete boot edge edge a performance by the
chicks
is that is that the new name for the
dixie chicks i think it is
um mayor keisha lance bottoms senator
tammy baldwin and senator tammy
duckworth
senator chris coons i could have sworn
he was on the program
a two days ago i guess he's back on it
but there will be a performance by john
legend in common
andrew yang will be uh speaking michael
bloomberg john meacham dr
vivek murthy congresswoman deb halland i
don't know who a lot of these people are
secretaries of state alex padilla and
jocelyn benson
and then vice president joe biden and
then there's an after party if you can
imagine that
hosted by andy cohen uh
okay so a big big night a big night
planned and they will be starting
around the top of the hour if not
shortly
thereafter um
corey price says thank god where you
been bro let's get it i'm here
i i'm here and we're doing it right now
caledon
says one year and many more to go yeah
caledon subscribing for 12 months over
on twitch prime
donald trump did give a completely
unhinged
press event earlier um look at some of
this i mean
these were the rantings of a lunatic
just take a listen to some of the stuff
he said and we'll see how triggered he
is today
during the event we're doing great in
new hampshire these are real polls these
are suppression polls
these aren't polls where they do
registered voters registered
no you want to do voters that are going
to vote registered voters
you want to do what's called likely
voters likely in other words people that
are likely to vote not registered voters
many of whom have died okay so there's
that
uh what else does aaron have for us um
oh this was just complete like i don't
know what he's talking about in this one
gotta tell the truth about things
and he's gonna do a lot better if he
does but hopefully not well enough
right now we are leading
a war that's incredible but right now
we're leading
in so many polls that they refuse to put
out we're doing so good
in this state in north carolina
in florida yeah okay i mean it's just
it's crazy what he's even talking about
um
let's see here's one where he tells a
personal story about boxer larry holmes
but i guess
botch is his name you the american
people
from scranton to easton how's ernie
doing good
huh how good is ernie right yeah
is he great ernie holmes he was
heavyweight
heavyweight champ right the chair larry
larry sorry about that i know another
one name ernie holmes
larry holmes is he still in the area of
uh
how good was larry right that was
probably
muhammad ali's most
dangerous fight i can't even take it
then trump again on a rant about indoor
plumbing
uh little things and they laugh at it
when i say it the light bulb
those new expensive light bulbs i said
what happened to the old ones they're
better
they said they were mandated out i said
why nobody could explain why
i said we're letting them back the light
bulbs are back
dishwashers they have dishwashers they
don't give you any water they give you
not enough water so they're lousy
so what do people do they press the
button again and again no water
i let them have lots of water we just
got back from whirlpool in ohio
they're thriving now because of what i
did
to competition from other countries i
tariffed him and whirlpool now went from
a company that was just about over
to a company that's thriving it takes a
high a high uh you really need a power
flush to satisfy
uh donald trump um
anyway all right let's just do i mean
let's do one more let me find a really
crazy
one um clean the forests is pretty crazy
blast of pa governor i don't even it's
not even clear
let's see what this one is this will be
a surprise i repealed
that horrible tax so many taxes how many
taxes did i repeal you know i'm getting
a list of them now i'll have it for you
for the next meeting
because i'll be back to pennsylvania
that i promise
yeah i don't know i don't know what he's
talking about i really don't
um oh trump attacked joe biden for
leaving scranton when he was
ten years so tonight we have slojo
will speak at the democrat convention
and i'm sure that he'll just knock him
dead
and he'll remind us that he was born in
scranton
but you know he left like 70 years ago
right
he left a long time ago he wanted one
you know i view it differently
he'd say he was born here but he left
that he was like eight nine or ten
so he left 68 years ago he left
long time ago so i view it differently
he wasn't born here
he abandoned scranton wow yeah so
something very very wrong with uh with
the president there so that was earlier
today in pennsylvania
bizarre completely completely bizarre
um okay i have some super chats to look
at
jr asks david whatever happened to the
quiet resistance in the trump
administration
that made itself known back in september
of 18
was that even a real thing to start i i
don't know
i'm not sure about that azar says dead
people voted in michigan turns out they
were alive when they cast their ballot
but died before the august election the
system of checks and balances works
the votes were not counted okay don't
know too much about that
uh jr says recently you fear too many
people are becoming complacent in this
election other than voting and
conversations how do you see
an active non-complacency work well
those are the things now everybody has
to vote and make sure others vote that i
mean
we're down to eight you know two and a
half months at this point uh
barely more than two months so and then
afterwards
check out my endless endless videos
about activism that works
and then ricky says hey david when do
states become swing states or are those
pretty much set in stone
i don't know what the technical
definition of a swing state is i don't
know if it's
it's gone to both you know one or the
other party
at least once in the last x number of
cycles
i'm not uh i'm not exactly sure how you
define it
but you know it when you see it that's
for sure let me say a big thank you to
peter mcmanus
peter is new member number one today at
joinpakman.com
and i have a good feeling that today
we're going to get our 50 members and
patrons
and we're going to open up the phone
lines i just i don't know i have this
feeling
last day of the dnc
have a sense it's going to happen i
really do
zest the african says from the
standpoint of
bing bing bong and washers
considering that trump is closing the
gap on biden
what should biden do differently going
forward i don't know that there's much
biden can do differently
we knew that this was not going to be a
15 point win for joe biden
we knew that as we got closer uh to
the next phase of the virus and
hopefully at some point a vaccine we
knew trump would try to take credit for
it and some fraction of the electorate
would fall for it and vote for trump
because
they think he had something to do with
the vaccine we knew all of it okay
so it's really going to come down to
turnout that's it's fundamentally where
we are
and what it is at this point um there
there's really no other
way way to say it quite frankly and that
may not be good for us it may be good
for us remember they're planning to
suppress
suppress the vote as powerfully as they
can and
that's something that we it's it's more
reason that we're going it's going to
have to be an overwhelming win
uh period period end of story nothing
else to
even say about it by the way did you all
hear that steve bannon got arrested and
indicted today
because it turns out he like many other
people associated with donald trump
was a crim is is accused of being a
criminal and has uh
been accused of committing crimes and uh
they they relate to that stupid
we build the wall it was this vet
who just raised money to build the wall
himself raised i think about 25 million
bucks
steve bannon was involved trump now
claims that he never was in favor of
that movement he said it today the truth
is he had spoken in favor of the
movement a while ago i mean
it's just crazy it's cr it there's so
many scandals so now it's
uh michael cohen paul manafort
roger stone steve bannon papadopoulos
carter p you know it's just on and on
and on
it's just a gang of of criminals quite
frankly
um melissa hosfeld says man
can't believe eight-year-old biden
bailed on scranton
uh wtf is donald j trump talking about
as always yeah it's incoherent it's
completely and totally incoherent it
makes no sense whatsoever
um and the rants about the toilets i
mean it's like what is trump doing in
the bathroom
that his obsession with water pressure
and toilets it's absolutely and
completely bizarre
um okay oh people wanting an update
on the
projection for a million subscribers
yeah i haven't looked today let's take a
look at where we are subscriber
milestone
uh october 25th now the projected date
where we will pass
one million subscribers on youtube
that's exciting the goal was election
day and we're on track for it
we just crossed over into 957 000.
we're only 43 this is like the home
stretch we are
uh we we we are the vast majority of the
way there 957 000 as of right now
on track if we can keep the pressure up
for a million on october 25th so i
appreciate everybody that's been
involved in participating in that that's
going to be a big deal
and by the way we also passed 45 000 on
twitch i've only been on twitch
12 months and that's very exciting
as well uh unclear when we're projected
to hit a million on twitch that yeah
that
that i don't have an easy answer to
offhand um i'll have to run some numbers
but it's certainly
years away would be my guess dominic
richardson says
is biden more progressive than obama
well his platform is
biden's climate platform and the
milestones that it includes
are more aggressive than what barack
obama had in his
uh on health care biden's running on
something to the left of obama he's
running on
obamacare plus public option lower
medicare buy-in by five years
etc so yeah i mean it's not the
progressive dream
but i think on just about every issue
biden is running to obama's left and it
makes sense
it's been four years and the country has
moved to the left
thanks to tina g for grabbing a youtube
membership at the soyboy level
and also a big thank you to mikhail
browning who is new member number two
today
at joinpakman.com i do appreciate that
very very much
the coupon code is live 2020 now
and we'll see if we get those phone
lines open today
thomas demayola says with all the
mcdonald's he probably eats it's not
difficult to imagine
why trump has an obsession with fixing
plumbing issues that's pretty good i
like that one
well said thomas you really have a way
with words that's clever
that's clever i like that one this is um
california
governor gavin newsom we are just about
a minute from the scheduled start
we will be hearing from joe biden
tonight but it's if you're just joining
us it's a
huge list of people we're gonna hear
from
bloomberg yang senator chris coons again
senators tammy baldwin and tammy
duckworth the two tami's
mayor keisha lance bottoms the the band
formerly known as the dixie chicks will
perform
pete boot edge edge will perform i will
speak
senator cory booker we're going to hear
from um john
john meacham i don't know exactly who dr
vivek murthy is but i'm interested
i'm interested minnie will be speaking
tonight and then we're also going to be
keeping a close eye on donald trump's
twitter
yesterday trump was hugely triggered
during barack obama's speech and i guess
he scheduled a diversion
he will be interviewed by sean hannity
tonight at 9 00 pm
so that's certainly something you could
tune into if you wanted i guess
if you have to oof gotham says
kuke and zuke update please so my urban
garden
the zukes are almost dead so i was away
for like nine days
and it was drought big drought powerful
drought and the zooks
are not looking so good although i'm
trying to rescue them
the cukes are looking very good i've
already pickled one of them
and i'm looking very very strongly at
throwing a few more in my
picklebrine pretty soon
uh tanner captanoglu says love the show
david good luck in pog
champs baba bowie and sarah stein says
what on earth do we do about the
electoral college so scary
well we're not going to be able to do
anything between now and november
so i believe we're going to have to do
something
after november i don't think we can do
anything about it
in the immediate uh i mistakenly said
yesterday that twitch subscriptions were
60 and 40 off i was wrong
i was wrong about that and i apologize i
was misinformed i've been told
that it is actually 20 off so that was
just a mistake david gardner
says david postal service agents
arrested bannon i don't know if that's a
joke i can't imagine that that's true
stephen does stuff says hey david i'm
out of town away from family
will you give a shout out to my fiancee
anastasia thanks absolutely anastasia
maybe soon to be anastasia does stuff
uh big shout out i'm sure i'm sure
stephen misses you
um aaron dadas oh maybe postal agents
did arrest um
uh bannon because why is wire fraud
considered a mail scam i'm not even sure
why they oh they aided in the universe
okay all right well we don't know it may
be true
aaron dadas has grabbed a soy boy
membership and sabres man says the rnc
is going to be a horror show
yeah i anticipate it's going to be
insane
absolutely insane and i'll be back with
you guys on monday
for the rnz rnc of course
thanks to grungy dan for the support on
twitch
chakuseki says there is a new radical
not
q anon conspiracy theory
involving dillary clinton beware of
fringe elements from david's veggie
garden well said
well said i couldn't have said it better
myself
jay heyman has subscribed with prime
alex kepcke says do the sir routine okay
the sir routine is when trump says
they came to me they said sir i'm having
to flush toilets 10 or 15 times i said
we got to fix that
we got to fix that so we're going to do
it we're going to do it sleepy joe won't
sleepy joe sleepy joe doesn't even know
where he is he abandoned scranton but
we're going to do it yeah they
they said sir uh whatever
what whatever is wrong with the water
pressure i'm able to flush nothing so
we're going to take care of it these
dems
with their special light bulbs and their
toilets we're going to fix it for you
very soon
okay our bread has cheered
over on twitch which i very much
appreciate
traced havoc says do you think the
situation with the post office will be
rectified
before the election no in other words
what are the chances of a funding bill
passing the senate so i think that
unfortunately too much damage has been
done
louis de joy announced that he would be
no doing no more to the post office
but he may have already done too much
that's what scares me
neptune says what should president biden
do with space force i don't that's
actually a good question i don't know
um maybe he should turn it into um
some kind of scientific endeavor for
exploring rather than
militarizing space majora says
in before a million cheers david
appreciate your grind and
everything you do thank you i appreciate
that
we do have a hype train leaving the
station we've not successfully
completed one at all this entire
dnc phase um
oz rogers says should sleepy joe
avoid debating trump for as long as
possible the
the debates are scheduled so i don't
know what what you mean by as long as
possible
um it seems avoiding publicity has
worked so far for the biden campaign
yeah i mean i've said i don't care if he
debates i don't think
i don't need debates at any time uh
during this election at any point
really thank you to mitsuo
and waxwell who between the two of them
have gifted
15 subscriptions if you can believe it
kyle hopper says yo david loved the show
i joined pacman a couple months ago and
never got one of your powerful shout
outs do you
do you have to donate plasma for one you
do
you do and let's go to andrew yang i'm
andrew yang you might know me as the guy
who ran for president talking about math
in the future
unfortunately for all of us that future
is now
the pandemic has accelerated everything
if you're like me and my wife evelyn you
don't know if your child's school is
going to reopen this fall
72 percent of americans believe that
this is the worst
time we have ever experienced and 42
percent of the jobs that have been lost
millions of jobs will never return we
are in a deep dark hole and we need
leaders who will help us dig out
i know many politicians promise and then
fail to deliver
if you voted for trump or didn't vote at
all back in 2016
i get it right many of us have gotten
tired of our leaders seeming far removed
from our everyday lives
and we despair that our government will
ever rise to the challenges of our time
but we must give this country our
country a chance
to recover and recovery is only possible
with a change of leadership and new
ideas
bold and innovative policies that will
get help into your hands
in the midst of this crisis are now
possible but we need your help to turn
the page for our country in 75 days
we are here tonight to celebrate joe
biden's nomination as the democratic
candidate for president
i have gotten to know both joe and
kamala on the trail over the past year
the way you really get to know a person
when the cameras are off the crowds are
gone
it's just you and them they're real
people they understand the problems we
face
there are parents and patriots who want
the best for us in our country
and if we give them the chance they will
fight for us and our families every
single day
our future is now and it is daunting but
i ask you tonight to join me to help joe
and kamala fight for the promise of
america
turn the page for our country and lead
us forward to a future we'll actually be
proud to leave to our children
and now i'd like to turn it over to a
great democrat who'll be with us
throughout the evening
between the two of us we have 11 emmys
how's that for math one of my favorite
actresses julia louis dreyfus
hi andrew i'm so glad to see you so what
did you think about kamala harris's
speech last night
it was tremendous i was so happy for her
i know me too she's fabulous i cannot
wait to see her debate our current vice
president
mika pines or uh is it paints
it's pronounced ponce i believe oh some
kind of weird foreign name oh boy
yeah not very american sounding yeah
that's what people are saying
strongly well uh thank you andrew and
i think it's good to hear from yang
because there's kind of a cult of
personality around him and some people
who might only vote if he says to
julia thank you so much good evening
america and welcome to the fourth night
of the 2020 democratic national
convention uniting america okay these
last few nights have been going
so well we've decided to add a fifth
night where we will just play michelle
obama's speech
on a loop oh no five nights i can't tell
you i first
met joe biden when i was doing my show
veep
i played the vice president and he was
in fact the vice president
and we hit it off immediately soon after
i was asked to be on the cover of a
magazine remember those
hype train just happened by the way it
was like oh what's it going to be
people or vogue or rolling stone
well it turns out it was for arrive the
official
onboard magazine of amtrak
which nobody ever reads even though it's
free
and the day it came out my phone rang
and it was the vice president telling me
he loved the cover
and the whole article and that it was
one of the best issues of arrive
he had ever read and that is just one of
the
many reasons that i wanted to be here
tonight for joe
and to remind you that joe biden not
only knows how to read
but also he reads everything
right you know i am no policy expert and
i certainly
don't pretend to be one but i have a gut
feeling about fairness and what's right
and that is why i am
so excited that just in a little while
we're going to hear from joe biden about
his plans for america
plans for a strong economy that helps
working people
and small businesses not just
billionaires and plans to raise the
wages for the nurses and teachers and
grocery workers
that are getting us through this crisis
god love them
so how can you help joe it's super
simple
vote right now you can text vote
to 30330 to learn about all of your
voting options and make the best plan
for
how to vote in your community everybody
needs a plan an easy way to remember
30330 is that's the year
donald trump will finally release his
tax returns
if we all vote there is nothing facebook
fox news and vladimir putin can do to
stop us
but first let's reaffirm the
all-american values that our party
and joe biden stand for right
i pledge allegiance to the flag
of the united states of america and to
republic
for which it stands one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
[Music]
what so proudly we
twilight's last gleaming
who's brought stripes and bright stars
through the peril
[Music]
streaming
the rocket's red glare
the bombs bursting in
air gave proof
through the night that our
flag was still there
oh say does that star
spangled
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
r
and the hope
of the
brave
all right the band formerly known as the
sister simone campbell
executive director of network and leader
of nuns on the bus
tonight marks an important next chapter
in our story
all right while the nuns on the bus do
their thing
um i do want to say uh
read a few super chats shion says
nothing gets the youth vote like joe
reading arrive
stacy says hey i joined a while back and
never got nothing no how okay i'm sorry
about that stacy thank you for joining
adrian martinez says you rock way better
than tim poole oh boy
shots fired matt chavez says you skipped
my super chat david you owe me two
dollars
i didn't see it adidia
dakshin amorthy says not important in
the grand scheme of things but i wanted
to ask why does your voice get so nasal
when you speak spanish oh my god
what a what a lame question um
jonathan mccartney says if biden wins
how do we criticize him from the left
without fracturing the overall left-wing
coalition in the u.s
once he's president that's not really a
big concern that i have
ellie laker says have you seen the list
of maniacs that will be speaking at the
rnc looks like it's going to be a real
freak show
yeah so the cut the st louis couple who
uh uh uh got their guns and pointed them
at protesters will be speaking
one of the covington kids will be
speaking a bunch of trump's children
are going to be speaking um
it's it's going to be insane it's going
to be absolutely and completely insane
um thank you to sky selenite
who's new member number three on my
website and dylan
n thoven whose new member number four
at joinpackman.com consider yourself
invited to join in chakuseki
says grumpy and dumpy bunker boy donald
trump's buddy bannon arrested for fraud
can we finally cast them off onto the
dung heap of history
boater fraud uh i
agree with everything there tristan
mcnic tristan michelle
rather says do you see biden running for
two terms i don't know
i don't know crypto monkey says is it
really fair
to send trump and pence into a battle of
wits when they are completely
unarmed we're gonna see very soon here's
senator chris coons
and change from abolition and women's
suffrage to the labor movement and the
struggle for civil rights
joe biden will continue that progressive
march towards justice
inspired by respect for the dignity of
all people people joe believes were made
in the image of god
joe learned that from his parents and
the nuns and priests right here in
delaware who taught him
and inspired in him a passion for
justice i'm senator chris coons of
delaware
and i want to tell you about my friend
joe biden his faith is strong
and it's personal and private for joe
faith isn't a prop or a political tool
i've known joe about 30 years and i've
seen his faith in action
joe knows the power of prayer and i've
seen him in moments of joy and triumph
of loss and despair turn to god for
strength
joe's comforted me in my toughest
moments as he has so many others
i'll never forget how joe took the time
to offer me words of comfort
as my father lay in hospice time and
again i've seen him
stop everything and listen really listen
to someone who needs a shoulder to cry
on
or partner in prayer that compassion
that empathy is part of his character
more than anything joe is a man of faith
and conscience
he'll be a president for americans of
all faiths as well as people of
conscience who practice
no particular faith joe's faith is
really about our future
about a world with less suffering and
more justice where we're better stewards
of creation
where we have a more just immigration
policy and where we call out and
confront the original sins of this
nation
the sins of slavery and racism joe knows
these are central issues in this
election
and for him they're rooted in faith joe
knows that it's faith it sustains so
many ordinary americans
who do extraordinary things nurses who
brave infection
firefighters who run into burning
buildings teachers working overtime
especially now they all deserve a
servant leader
who knows the dignity of work who sees
them respects them
fights for them we need a president who
brings people
of all faiths together to tackle our
challenges rebuild
our country and restore our humanity
someone who knows we're called
to do justice love mercy and walk humbly
with our god
joe biden will be that president joe's
always known this race is a battle for
the soul of our country
and he's right joe believes he believes
in both the greatness and the goodness
of this country
he believes in us and in what we can do
together
my question is what is your faith
and how would you use your faith in
making decisions for our nation
[Music]
reverend uh i kind of know what it's
like to lose
uh family and uh
my heart goes out to you you may
remember
after barack and michelle and i were
there my family
i came back on that sunday the regular
service
because i just lost my son and um
i wanted some hope because what you all
did
was astounding i don't know if you all
know this
all those who died were killed
by this white supremacist they forgave
him
they forgave him the ultimate act of
christian charity
they forgave him and you know reverend
um i'm not proselytizing i happen to be
a practicing catholic
but i went back to the church because i
found particularly
the black church in this case with an
amy
it was not an episcopal church
i found that um there's that famous
phrase from kierkegaard
faith sees best in the dark i find the
one thing it gives me
and i'm not trying to process i'm not
trying to convince you to be
to share my religious views but for me
it's important because it gives me
some reason to have hope and
purpose okay
just remember joe biden goes to church
so regularly
that he doesn't even need tear gas and a
bunch of federalized troops to help him
get there
well said no one fought harder
for your right to vote than john lewis
here to speak about him and his legacy
we have one of our great mayors
atlanta's keisha lance bottoms mayor
bottoms hello
i know that you are you're recovering
from the coronavirus
how are you feeling
well good evening i feel really good
thank you for asking
my husband on the other hand is still
having many of the lingering side
effects that people talk about but all
in all our family is doing great
well i'm glad to hear it but boy i think
a lot of americans
are going to be dealing with that for a
long time
hey mayor i wanted to ask you something
is atlanta ready for election day
we will be ready and we are going to do
everything that we can to make sure that
voting goes smoothly but we are
encouraging people
if you can vote early in your state to
please
do so early vote during the early vote
perfect excellent advice over 40 states
now
allow some form of early voting okay
stay
safe mayor and i turn it over to you
well thank you julia and good evening
i'm keisha lance bottoms a mother of
four
and mayor of atlanta georgia cradle of
the civil
rights movement and like so many other
cities
a place where the struggle for human
dignity
continues i'm proud to have grown up in
this city
educated in its public schools and
blessed to have known
our hometown heroes like dr joseph lowry
dr
c.t vivian and our teacher our friend
our conscience our congressman
john lewis he walked gently amongst us
not as a distant icon but as a
god-fearing
man who did what he could to fulfill
the as yet unfulfilled promise of
america
people often think that they can't make
a difference
like our civil rights icons but
every person in the movement mattered
those who made the sandwiches
swept the church floors stuffed the
envelopes
they too changed america and so
can we the baton has now been passed to
each of us
we've cried out for justice we have
gathered in our streets to demand
change and now we must pass on the gift
john lewis sacrificed to give us we must
register and we must vote
in his parting essay written to us
congressman lewis expressed his pride in
the activism that has swept our country
and he reminded us that if we fail
to exercise our right to vote we
can lose it there are those who are
disgracefully
using this pandemic to spread
misinformation
and interfere with voting forcing
many in 2020
to still risk their lives to exercise
their sacred
right to vote a right that has already
been paid for with the blood sweat tears
and lives of so many so
let's stand up for our children our
children's children and for this great
democracy
that our ancestors work to build and
let's vote
and let's organize to get others to vote
with us
you can help make this happen by texting
vote
two three zero three three zero
we know how important it is that we
elect
real leaders like joe biden and kamala
harris
people of honor and integrity who hold
justice close to their hearts and
believe that the lives
of my four black children
matter in the words of womanist poet
audre lorde
your silence will not protect you
congressman lewis would not be silenced
and neither can we we cannot wait
for some other time some other place
some other heroes
we must be the heroes of our generation
because we too are america our
votes can be our voice
[Music]
all right very important messages there
and a lot of messages coming in from you
guys
jacob ball says i for one am outraged
the dixie chicks were invited to sing
after they so disrespectfully refused to
blindly support
another war well said hadwell says how
many trump supporters does it take to
screw in a light bulb none trump just
says it is and they all stand in the
dark and cheer
that's not bad adam bellows says your
take on why democrats brought up guns at
the dnc as if that issue's not obvious
seems better to silently drop the
assault weapons ban
and touch that hot stove yeah we
addressed that yesterday
sabrina zafar says honest thoughts on
kennedy v markey in massachusetts i have
at least one probably two or three
videos about this
and i'm i'm voting for ed markey
over on twitch um a lot of discussions
about
salads and freedom jesus
gifted five subscriptions which is both
important
and exciting neptune says do you think
trump will run in 2024 if he loses i
literally have a segment about that on
today's podcast and the answer is no
he will not um heidi david you you may
want to delete the live stream that was
started by accident okay yeah that's
been done
big sos man says our species must
outgrow god and religion
violettus is my father
okay boy this is a long question it's
another assault weapons ban question
um and she says answer in english and
she'll
translate okay so the question is that
her dad is asking whether i believe that
banning assault weapons
and high-capacity uh uh
assault weapons and or high-capacity
magazines affects the democratic party
and that it will lose centrists
and uh republicans who don't like trump
um i don't think it makes that much
sense to talk about gun policy
this particular election because it
ranks extremely low
on the list of what matters to voters
it's coronavirus economy and race
relations are the top three and those
together are i don't remember what
percentage but a lot a lot of what
voters care about
so i don't think it's a huge advantage
to talk about guns at all really
um xi'an says david could you make an
rnc bingo card
now that's a good idea we should have an
rnc bingo bingo card for next week
email me through my website if you have
things you think should be in the
squares and i'll put together an rnc
bingo card shannon bennis
says did you see that hhs gave primary
covet 19 data collection back to cdc
too many elements of improprieties i did
not see that yet
andrew says in spanish tantos elementos
the cringe in
the convention democratic
okay so he says too many elements of
cringe in this democratic convention
they all sound like robots
that's andrew coming in very strongly
with a spanish super chat
i want to say thanks to i can tell that
this is an icelandic name
but i am i have no idea how to pronounce
it
ragnar sigurd daughter
sigurdur daughter oh my god okay i i
apologize but you are new member number
five and i believe that
that's someone checking in from iceland
david glover is new member number six
and gary grothhouse is new member number
seven
certainly those are easier for me to
pronounce uh
i just don't understand how to say
icelandic names very difficult for me
paul milbank says i want this religious
nonsense out of the dnc if you believe
that's fine but church is your platform
our politics is supposed to be secular
i tend to agree with that i tend to
agree with that
uh blake i eat steaky
subscribed with prime with the message
david
you demand thank you dave pratt
says in addition to dejoy's sabotage are
you
also concerned about the state's ability
to tally absentee votes
i'm concerned about every aspect of this
upcoming election there is no
aspect you could name that i'm not
concerned with
stephen whiteside says are after 15
years are you are you at all tired of
covering politics
yes and that is why tonight i am going
to announce
that when the show ends
on uh this is a very important day
actually
when the show wraps up on friday
september 11th
the 19th anniversary of 9 11
we will be ending all shows
for a period of one week we will be
taking a vacation and then we'll be back
so that will be that
it will be ours
when the war is won we will be
sure we will be sure
oh glory glory
[Music]
no man no weapon formed against yes
glory is destined
everyday women and men become legends
sins that go against our skin become
blessed this is just unless
the rhythm to us freedom is like
religion to us
justice is just a position in us justice
for all just
ain't specific enough once son died his
spirit is revisiting us
true and living living in us resistance
is us
that's why rosa sat on the bus that's
why we walk through america
with our hands up when it go down we
woman and man
up they say stay down and we stand up
shots be on the ground the camera panned
up king pointed to the mountaintop and
we ran
up one day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
when it's all done we'll cry
[Music]
now for every man woman and child even
jesus
got his crown in front of a crowd they
marched with the torch we gon run with
it now
never look back we didn't go hundreds of
miles from dark roads
heroes to become a hero facing the
league of justice
power was the people enemy is lethal a
king became rico
saw the face of tim crow under a ball
the biggest weapon
is to stay peaceful we sing our music is
the cuts that we bleed through
somewhere in a dream had an epiphany
now we write the wrongs in history no
one can win a war
individually and take the wisdom of the
elders
young people's energy welcome to the
story we call
victory the coming of the lord my eyes
have seen the glory
one day when the glory comes
it will be
[Music]
we will be sure
[Music]
[Music]
when it's all shredded
we'll cry
[Music]
okay wow that was so beautiful john in
common wow
joe biden shares john lewis's belief
that every vote matters personally
i plan to follow the example of six
current cabinet members
vice president poonts and president
trump himself
and vote by mail to find out everything
you need to know about
mail and ballots your polling place or
even just am i registered
text vote to 30330
30330 that would be the president's golf
score
if he didn't cheat okay look
i'll admit that was a little nasty but
we all know he's a cheater
and i'm proud to be a nasty
nasty woman you know when donald trump
spoke at his inauguration about american
carnage i
assumed that was something he was
against not a campaign promise
what we need now is great leadership
someone experienced and hard-working and
intelligent
someone who understands the soul of the
american
people
i'm historian john meacham okay
so um there are a whole bunch of
messages that people are people are
sending over to me
um let's see here uh
okay i'm not sure about that jacob ball
says hillary clinton needs to be the
first the free space on any rnc bingo
card not a bad idea
dave whoa hold on a second where did
that go
david vadolazki
says thoughts on biden transition lead
ted kaufman telling ws
the wall street journal they're
preparing an austerity agenda already
didn't see it i'll have to look at that
david cookmeyer says thank you for
giving a voice on youtube to the left
my pleasure and twitch as well tenavres
just subscribed on twitch and says i sub
so that you can keep that head of hair
in check also for more chess lessons
from botez yeah that's coming up next
week
brink and juke hunter have subscribed
with prime
james buccino says is it possible trump
could run for a third term
no jason green says right now with
covid19
all originally live events that are
being translated to this type of format
are cringe i feel it is the nature of
the beast yeah to a certain degree it is
i don't disagree jonathan mccartney says
what's the left
the next step for the left if trump wins
let's cross that bridge when we come to
it but it's going to be very ugly for a
while if that happens let's
we don't none of us want to experience
that devastation on november 4th so
let's not
allow that to happen alex stevenson says
is there any possibility
you will be covering the movement for a
people's party convention
on august 30th probably
not because that's a sunday and weekends
off are
pretty important right now um some
people asking for captions over here all
right we can turn
some captions on um jacob
have to mariam says hey david have you
seen the huge trump ads on the youtube
home page my ad blocker can't block it
wonder how many folks they eventually
sway i have seen those
casey bates asks do you know if campaign
money goes to
artist or volunteer
i don't know what that means the
campaign money is for
ads and paying workers
artist or volunteer i don't know what
you mean i'm sorry
gail sal sends a super chat pudding pop
says
i think the campaign is going after
suburban women very strongly
that's why we're getting all this
religious stuff but we see a lot of jill
biden too
well i yeah i mean maybe later jill
biden already gave her speech
gail sal says david you're very handsome
just saying wow thank you i appreciate
that
daniel krieger says bernie declined to
endorse marky i wonder why
no idea no idea um
michigan mama says our music is the cut
we bleed
through goosebumps
mir the idea says why are you not
reading my super chats because they're
so lame and it's clearly the same person
as all the other people they just have a
penchant for sending lame
super chats uh master 101 says bingo
card idea alternating between
maga and kag keep america great yeah
that there's gonna have to be a lot of
that for sure
people asking if the phone lines are
opening well
maybe if we get to 50 website members
and patrons
then the phone lines will indeed open
the coupon code works joinpakman.com
works
everything's i've never seen things work
as well as they're working tonight
let me put it that way for you and we
will
uh yeah it's we're already more than a
quarter of the way into night four
i expect we will hear from joe biden in
about an hour i would say
at about 10 40 would be my guess with
probably
a 25 minute speech going five minutes
past 11.
i'm just guessing i don't i don't know
that seems to be the way
um that that they do it david moss says
who's your favorite chess player
i i don't have one i don't know i love
your style of journalism
and melissa i don't know what that means
my style of journalism and melissa
all right adidia dakshinamorthy
says your thoughts on criticism of the
dnc's message of threat to democracy
ignoring the real issues of people today
eviction
job wage loss since the pandemic et
cetera well they've mentioned that as
well i don't think it's wrong
to do the big systemic critiques at all
um
but i think that they've also been been
dealing with some of the immediate
impact
of the coronavirus and i i think that
there's been a pretty good mix of both
okay let's see what's next here helpful
to be with you here
on indigenous land the promise of this
country is older than our constitution
over 500 years ago thousands of indian
tribes were vibrant democratic societies
with rich cultures and traditions in
communities that had sustained them for
millennia
on lands they loved and respected my
people
the pueblo indians migrated to the rio
grande valley in the late 1200s
to escape droughts we were led to the
great river and its tributaries
where we established an agricultural
tradition that continues to this day
my people survived centuries of slavery
genocide and brutal assimilation
policies
but throughout our past tribal nations
have fought for
and helped build this country there were
those like my laguna grandparents who
worked on our country's railroad
and those like my mother a navy veteran
who served this country with honor i
stand here today
a proud 35th generation new mexican
and one of the first native american
women ever elected to congress
i'm a symbol of our resilience as the
embodiment
of america's progress as a nation
i know we can't take our democracy for
granted especially now
as people are dying as our land is
abused as our constitution
is under attack we must work for it
by getting involved by registering
voters
by voting voting is sacred
why people know that we weren't
universally granted the right to vote
until 1962
and that fundamental right is more
important than ever
whether your ancestors have been here
for hundreds of years
or you're a new citizen know this
whether we vote and how we vote will
determine
if our nation's promise of social racial
and environmental justice
will outlast us joe biden and kamala
harris respect our past and understand
our present
they will see us through this crisis of
leadership that is plaguing our country
and they will help us to build a better
future
thank you
the first year that i voted okay um
a lot happening that i want to keep up
with austin smith
as well as the valeria botvinnik
botvinic our new members number eight
and nine today
putting us at a very strong nine it's a
strong nine
um jacob ratner asking are you concerned
about the rise of
q in congress i am it's it's absolutely
batshit insane
matt the trucker says keep the
awesomeness going you
rock uh if you are watching on youtube
feel free to let me know what your
voting plan is
via super chat have you requested a
ballot uh are you planning to
send it in via mail deliver it in person
vote in person vote early in person vote
on november 3rd in person i would love
to hear from you
david r says via super chat david this
is feeling like hillary kane re-wrapped
with a heavy dose of identity politics
do you really think if they get into
office offense that overtake the senate
they'll push for the reforms bernie said
they would i hope so
i'm actually not seeing an overwhelming
amount of identity politics this time
around
um uh i i i'm just not seeing that
oh this i love sarah cooper let's see
what's going on will they be stolen from
mailboxes
as they get put in by the mailman will
they be taken from the mailmen and the
mail women
will they be forged who is signing them
who's signing them what are they signed
at a kitchen table and sent in
will they be counterfeited by groups
inside our nation
will they be counterfeited maybe by the
millions by foreign powers
let me put this in my own words i've
heard donald trump say some pretty
unhinged things i've heard them over and
over and over again
but nothing is more dangerous to our
democracy than his attacks
on mail and voting during a pandemic
okay here's the truth donald trump
doesn't want
any of us to vote because he knows her
real voice is nothing like trump's
so whether you plan to vote by mail or
in person
wearing your mask it is your vote
and it's your right don't let donald
trump take that away from you
for accurate up-to-date voting
information that you can trust
text vote to 30330
one more time text vote to 30-330
i'm alex padilla california secretary of
state
and i'm jocelyn benson so that was
actually
this must be a video because it was
actually on pause when they first went
to it which was really
weird um jordan singer says obamagate
needs to be on the bingo card maybe even
as the free space yeah we're i'm looking
at doing an rnc bingo card
feel free to email me uh through my
website contact form with your
suggestions for what should be on that
bingo card
julia bennis julian bennison says
watching from australia
it seems sad to me that the guy with all
the policy bernie is not the nominee
dnc not appealing to the progressive
left that's a big topic and i've dealt
with it ad nauseam so i'm not going to
do too much on that today
mazzy z says i'm voting in person i live
in a solid red state so honestly not
really worried about mail-in vote
tampering haha
logan ensley says tennessee requires a
reason to vote by mail and does not
accept
fear of covet as a valid reason
unfortunately i'll probably be voting in
person okay
jonathan mccartney says i'm voting from
japan i've already requested an absentee
ballot but i'm concerned about whether
or not
it will make it through my primary vote
did not
yikes mccoy boole
says i think he's going to quit before
november don't you he isn't trump
i don't think so i don't think he will
say i want to say thank you to elijah
lutz elijah lutz is new member number 10
today at joinedpakman.com and i do
appreciate that
i do have people are asking about my
um garden a lot of people obsessed with
the garden
let me see if i have any new posts up uh
no
i my last instagram post is a post with
a
puppy actually um so if you want to
break
from horrible uh the horrible reality of
what's going on in the country
um on my instagram there is a picture of
me with a puppy which some
people might like steve button says i'll
be making use of early voting in maine
we can vote in person at the town office
or city hall
30 days before election day that's good
news chris
stultz says i just moved to salt lake
city from new orleans and i have to say
the voting process is better here
all i needed was my social security card
to register
evan d says new trafalgar poll biden and
trump tied at 47 in minneapolis
in minnesota uh that's not good
sneakers and streets says how confident
are you about pogchamps
not confident at all jeremy jeremy
schwab
as in like trump has sent out a hundred
million schwabs
uh says keep on keeping on great
coverage
expose lies i plan to my friend
i plan to um okay let's see what else
we've got here america
if you were an immigrant back then come
from an immigrant family
the democrats brought you in we are in
danger of losing
the meaning of this country every
generation before us has
had to fight for what they believe in
and it's just our turn now
i was so proud when i saw the
demonstrations that were going on across
the country
this year's election means a lot to me
because i feel like
our generation is so motivated right now
to make a difference
there's a lot of changes that we have to
make and i'm counting on joe biden and i
believe in him
who's next cory booker i'm here
because a union job lifted my family out
of poverty
and into the middle class my grandfather
left the jim crow south for
detroit joined the uaw and got a job on
the assembly lines during world war
ii that union job enabled him to support
his family
raise my mom and send her to fisk
university
that's the american dream together we
work
together we rise joe biden and kamal
harris know the dignity of
all working americans they know the
urgency
and the demand of our dream but working
people
are under attack the wealth gap grows
our middle class shrinks
and poverty persists
last week donald trump said and i quote
our economy is doing good
while 40 million americans are at risk
of losing their homes
30 million aren't getting enough to eat
and 5.4 million people
have lost their health care because of
this crisis
he has failed us
but still i believe in the dream of our
ancestors
together with joe and kamala in the
white house will raise
the minimum wage so no one who works a
full-time
job in america lives in poverty together
will fight for those who keep us healthy
who keep us safe who teach our children
will stand for those who cook and serve
and clean who
plant and harvest who pack and
always those who deliver whose hands
are thick with calluses like my
granddads were
who lifted me high who held mine when i
was a boy
if he was alive joe
and kamala he would be so
proud of you and he tell us
take another by the hand and another and
let's get to work
this dream ain't free you gotta work for
it
so like his generation up and out of the
depression
let's now work together and stand
together
and america together we
will rise
wow nice little speech this is my team
you guys build america not wall street
you just build a man that's right
the americans just want to live meekly
comfortable i've got a wife that works
as well
we've got a 17 and a seven year old at
home and
and we're still working you know thanks
to our international executive
board for getting with general motors
and making sure that it's safe for us to
return back to work after eight weeks of
being laid off
i mean it's it's a hoax at one point and
now here we are full-blown yep well i
tell you what
the future of auto workers america and i
really believe this
it can be as bright as it was back in
the
in in the late 40s 50s yes
simple reason it's an iconic industry
it's an american industry
we made it we made it yes thank you
it's been a very interesting 2020. i've
been in the fire service
16 years and never experienced anything
like covid
uh we got to change our whole tactics
the way we did our day-to-day
and now at a hurricane that just came in
two weeks ago
and we were right almost right on the
eye and
i mean we're doing things we never
thought we'd be doing
water rescues in with mass on having to
worry about covid
it was it was interesting how's your
family doing
well i'm a single dad i have a almost
five-year-old who's my world
and i'm very lucky that my parents are
retired my mom actually retired
these conversations are interesting only
in that joe biden seems to be able to
talk to people like a normal person
which is just
trump can't do that and and it's just a
reminder of just how insane
the situation currently is online
schooling
staged or not trump can't even do it
staged you understand what i'm saying
or double income families in they're
just trying to figure out how they're
going to do it with their kids
what how what arrangements are they're
going to have to make sense
trump would now be saying yeah covet i
mean you know the china virus they
didn't have to leave china
it escaped or they let it out i don't
know we're looking into that
some people say one some people say the
other but you know we're pulling out
because of it we're out of the who
we're out of the wto because they got us
on trade and health
health and trade both we got and we
tariff them
these people are paying tariffs right
and the guy just said kovitz tough
that's all the guys said
the way middle-class people generate
wealth
overwhelmingly is building up equity in
their home
and that's what gets passed on from one
generation to the next the equity in a
home
you know the middle class is continuous
taking hits and
one of the reasons why we're on this
call is we realize how important it is
to
have you in the white house so at this
point trump would jump in and
jump in and say listen i'm all about the
middle class
obama left the cupboards bear for the
middle class and the blacks
the blacks did better than is that my
african-american over there
what a guy over there everybody's doing
great but then the virus hit we had to
turn it off
we had to turn it off but we'll turn it
back on and it'll be a v
it'll come right it's a whoa hold on the
guy's just talking about his family
solar facility outside of harrisburg you
know i'm a scranton boy you know
central pennsylvania's okay but you know
northeast
so keep the faith guys okay
all right continuing i know it's not
typical for a former surgeon general to
speak at a convention
surgeons general are appointed by
presidents but our work isn't about
politics
our highest duty is to the public our
true guide is science
and our job is to speak the truth about
public health
even when it's controversial or
perceived as political
so here's the truth our nation
absolutely has what it takes
to overcome the covet 19 pandemic let's
claim tens of thousands of our loved
ones
we have the talent resources and
technology
what we're missing is leadership we need
a leader who works with states
to ensure that everyone who needs a test
gets one and gets results quickly
a leader who secures a safe effective
vaccine
and distributes it quickly and fairly
a leader who inspires us to practice
distancing
and wear masks not as a political
statement
but as a patriotic duty a commitment we
make to one another
that's why i'm here tonight not because
of politics or for party
but because i know joe biden can be that
leader
i've worked with joe biden i've seen who
he is with no cameras around
how he sits with people in their pain
and holds them in his
heart how he pours over coveted
briefings
asking smart questions letting science
guide his way
just as he did when managing the ebola
crisis
and six years ago when joe biden met my
family
many of them immigrants ought to be in
the nation's capital
i saw how he kneeled beside my
grandmother's wheelchair
took her hands in his and said thank you
for choosing us
the united states of america as the
place to trust with your family
tonight as a father son and grandson
as a doctor who swore an oath and as an
american who loves my country
i can tell you that joe biden is the man
i trust
to look out for my family and the leader
i know
will heal this nation
nice guy i like this guy
hi i'm senator tammy baldwin when i was
nine years old
i got sick really sick i was
hospitalized but since my grandparents
were the ones raising me
and our family's health plan didn't
cover grandkids
they were forced to pay out of pocket
for my three-month hospital stay
that's insane i got better but the
insurance companies didn't
they refused to cover me at any cost
because i was marked
child with a pre-existing condition
we all have stories like this stories
about a time when the system was rigged
against us
when we were counted out left out pushed
out
just think of what we've heard these
past four days
health care professionals who don't have
the protective gear they need
young people whose asthma will get worse
as our air quality does
workers who are afraid of losing their
jobs
each story begs this simple fundamental
question
a question that gets to the heart of the
choice in this election
what kind of country do we want to be
do we want to be a country where
millionaires get to
dodge taxes or one where working
families get a break
do we want to be a country where medical
bills bury people in debt
or one where health care is affordable
for all
or where tens of thousands of people die
from a virus
or where the american dream lives
i think we know the answer to that
fundamental question
because most of us want the same things
good schools in our neighborhoods racial
justice
the freedom to love who we want dignity
in our work and an economy where small
businesses and working families thrive
and over the past months we've added
another to that list
a nation free from covid
that's why joe biden and kamala harris
are the only
answer in this election trust me
they are you see there's another part of
my story
the part where i ran for office the part
where i served in congress
the part where i worked with joe biden
and barack obama
to make sure kids and grandkids if their
dependents
can stay on their parents health
insurance until they're 26.
we got that done and yes it was a big
effing deal
love it that's the america i know
that's the america i love and that's the
america we will be
with joe biden and kamala harris in the
white house
a nation that plans a nation that builds
a nation that builds back say it with me
there at home
a nation that builds back better we'll
look at that soon here in wisconsin
our state motto is just one word
forward this november let's move forward
and
never look back thank you
thank you
no other nation no other nation can
match us
if we step up we lead by the power our
example not by the example of our power
the only thing that could tear america
apart is america itself
and we cannot let that happen
if you want to help joe and kamala make
sure that america stays strong
and united please go to joe biden.com
and contribute
anything that you possibly can tonight i
couldn't be prouder to be a loyal union
member
a passionate climate activist and a
democrat
or as donald trump will call me in a
tweet tomorrow
a washed up horse face no talent has
been with low ratings
with all due respect sir it takes one to
no one
and now i'd like to introduce you to a
real american hero
world war ii veteran ed goode
i am edward good i'm 95 years old
i'm a veteran of world war ii and of
korea oh this is interesting
when i wear a uniform i wear only two
badges
my parachute wings and the combat
infantry badge
i did make one combat jump over the
rhine
in germany and i'm proud of that
i have been a republican since the 1960s
i'm a member of the nra and uh
i voted for trump i think trump has
been the the worst president we've ever
had oh this should be good
so i'll be glad to see him go i think
joe biden will be a great leader for the
united states
like me on the day of my jump into
germany
i think joe biden cares about doing his
proper duty
for the united states and if he's
elected that's what he will do
imagine if trump goes after this guy
this year's election is very important
all right so somebody did send me elliot
sent me a possible
rnc bingo card which has some funny
stuff
um someone brags about the economy
pre-covet all lives matter someone
questions kamala's birthplace
trump says he's done more than any
president other than abe lincoln for
blacks
law and order someone mentions reagan
they're coming for your guns trump
brags about a cognitive test melania
plagiarizes michelle obama
bush family is mentioned trump says mail
in voting will lead to fraud
someone refers to benghazi transition to
greatness
well how did that just get checked oh
the creator must be checking stuff on it
that's funny
uh trump says crooked hillary anyway
okay so this is we're gonna put it
together if you have submissions
for a bingo board for next week
you can get them in by email
um bay photo once kamala's name is
mispronounced
i think we need that guts griffith says
bingo idea whenever these are brought up
bblm i immigration wall
and white nationalist talking points
going back to obama okay
all right that's that's complex thanks
for listening says they ganged up on
bernie so i'll hold my nose and vote
biden just like i did hillary already
stacking the deck against us
everybody needs to vote crystal die
says so grateful that i found you in
your streams and the bonus is that my
almost nine-year-old son
loves watching you with me and learning
about current events
that kid's got upper management written
all over them crystal
that is fantastic to hear
let me say thank you to riley ingle
who is new member number 11 today
we're shooting for 50 and we're not
doing quite so good right now
but you can grab a membership at
jointpakman.com and remember we are also
embroiled in a battle to one million
youtube subscribers
so if you're one of the beautiful five
nearly 6 000 people watching on youtube
please consider hitting that subscribe
button also thanks to utopiangamer
who has subscribed with twitch prime and
says appreciate you
the price of dreams says david you gotta
really lean into your what would trump
say you nail him thank you for your hard
work
really enjoy your take on things thank
you
and jamie says trump's response to
everything is reactive not proactive
that's why he's incompetent anyone who
takes him seriously is also incompetent
uh and cyrus palmer says loving the
trump impersonations
will fava wants producer pat merch
there's an idea
m.r howard says what do you think about
ranked choice voting being on the ballot
in massachusetts that's great
also just describe subscribe to your
channel for the fourth time hashtag
bots yeah we're using elements of bots
um jonathan brown bingo idea ted cruz
eats a booger yeah that has happened
right i think that should probably be on
there i think that's a good idea
and then shannon bennett says bingo idea
laura ingram eats a kitten
that i've never seen shady flakes says
we put in the public option because no
one wanted to man
up and ban all private insurance for
medicare for all yeah i've talked about
this before
you don't need to ban private insurance
to do medicare for all if medicare for
all is really good people will just step
away from
from private insurance you don't have to
worry about it and i think legally it
would be very difficult to ban private
insurance just
have an alternative that's so much
better that people say i don't need the
private insurance
thanks to nato jenkins for gifting five
subscriptions on twitch and
detatron for subscribing with prime
were actually 11 twitch subs from 1400
which is a nice uh
right nice round number uh linda heard
and mads zinc have grabbed youtube
subscriptions
both at the beta level beta
and remember that to avoid confusion the
only things that count up here towards
50
are website memberships at
joinpakman.com
and patrons here's senator tammy
duckworth good evening
i'm tammy duckworth when i first
enlisted in the army i was eager to
serve my country
yet anxious whether i'd be able to earn
my way into the ranks
but i earned my wings and later
commanded my own air assault unit
learning that serving and leading in the
military is both a privilege
and a sacrifice to be a commander you
must always put your troops first
because one day you may order them to
sacrifice everything for our great
nation
to do that leaders must command their
troops respect
and be worthy of their pledge to protect
and defend our constitution
no matter the cost but military service
doesn't just take sacrifice
from those in uniform it's required from
their families
too my husband brian was the one who
rushed to walter reed after i was
wounded in iraq
he was the one holding my hand waiting
for me to wake up
and when i finally did he was my rock
getting me through those hours
weeks months of unspeakable pain and
unending surgeries
he was my anchor as i relearned to walk
helping me through every step
and every stumble our military spouses
hold their families together praying for
their loved ones safety
wherever they're deployed and serving as
caregivers to our disabled service
members
and then picking up the pieces and
starting again whenever the next tour
or the next war arises joe biden
understands these sacrifices
because he's made them himself when his
son beau
deployed to iraq his burden was also
shouldered by his family
joe knows the fear military families
live because he's felt that dread of
never knowing if your deployed loved one
is safe
he understands their bravery because he
has had to muster that same strength
every hour of every day bo was overseas
that's the kind of leader our service
members deserve
one who understands the risks they face
and who would actually protect them
by doing his job as commander-in-chief
instead they have a coward in chief who
won't stand up to vladimir putin
read his daily intelligence briefings or
even publicly admonish
adversaries for reportedly putting
bounties on our troops heads
as president joe biden would never let
tyrants manipulate him like a puppet
he would never pervert our military to
stroke his own ego
he would never turn his back on our
troops or threaten them against
americans
peacefully exercising their
constitutional rights
joe biden would stand up for what's
right stand tall for
our troops and stand strong against our
enemies
because unlike trump joe biden has
common decency
he has common sense he can command
both from experience and from strength
donald trump doesn't deserve to call
himself commander-in-chief for another
four
minutes let alone another four years
nice
our troops deserve better our country
deserves better if you agree text more
to 30330 to elect joe biden
a leader who actually cares enough about
america
to lead meanwhile trump's vietnam was
avoiding
stds so there's that
and joe biden is my dad
some voices are never silenced
some work never ceases to change lives
some people never stop inspiring
even after they're gone po biden was a
husband
father brother son
soldier attorney general he was given
just 46 years on this earth he did in 46
years what most of us couldn't do in
146.
think about the day that dawn's for
children who are safer
because of both whose lives are fuller
because of him
think about the day that dawns for
parents who rest easier
and families who are freer because of
him
some folks may never know that their
lives are better because of beau biden
but that's okay certainly for beau
acclaim
was never the point of public service if
you knew beau
you knew he lived by the strictest code
of honor
duty service country
you never had to ask if he would do
something the right way
he didn't know any other way bowden cut
corners
he turned down an appointment to be
delaware's attorney general
so he could win it fair and square when
the field was clear for him to run for
the senate he chose
to finish his job as a.g instead
after 9 11 he joined the national guard
he felt it was his obligation
he did his duty to his country and
deployed to iraq
beau biden served his country in battle
he prosecuted one of the worst child
predators in american history
and even though he is no longer with us
every day he still inspires
the next president of the united states
it won't be possible for me to be here
this fall so i have something to ask of
you
be there for my dad like he was for me
wow a couple of years ago
i was diagnosed with cancer
and i was absolutely terrified
one of the first people who called me
was joe
his real warmth and kindness on that
call
man i gotta say it made me cry
our current president has made me cry
too but it's
never had anything to do with his warmth
or kindness
joe biden's empathy is genuine you can
feel it
that's why president obama asked joe to
head up the cancer moonshot
president obama knows what we all know
joe biden
understands suffering and loss and
sacrifice
mayor pete buttige also knows something
about sacrifice
he volunteered and was deployed to
afghanistan then returned home to
indiana to become
a highly effective public servant say hi
to mayor pete pete edge edge coming up
next
good evening beau biden lived a life of
service
in office and in uniform when you put
your life on the line for this country
you do it not because it's the country
you live in but because it's a country
you believe in
i believe in this country because
america
uniquely holds the promise of a place
where everyone can belong
we know that for too many and for too
long
that promise has been denied but we also
know
america is at its best when we make that
circle of belonging
wider just over 10 years ago
i joined a military where firing me
because of who i am
wasn't just possible it was policy
now in 2020 it is unlawful in america to
fire someone
because of who they are or who they love
the very ring on my finger a wedding we
celebrated
here where i'm standing reflects how
this country can change
love makes my marriage real but
political courage
made it possible including that of joe
biden
who stepped out ahead even of this party
when he said
that marriage equality ought to be the
law of the land
there is a long way to go but if this
much can change between 2010 and 2020
imagine what could change between now
and 2030.
imagine what we could achieve this
coalition we are building
this very season gathering progressives
and moderates
independence and even what i like to
call future former republicans
standing for an america where everyone
belongs
joe biden is right this is a contest for
the soul
of the nation and to me that contest is
not between good americans and evil
americans
it's the struggle to call out what is
good in
every american
it's up to us will america be a place
where faith
is about healing and not exclusion
can we become a country that lives up to
the truth that black
lives matter will we handle questions of
science and medicine
by turning to scientists and doctors
good idea
will we see to it that no one who works
full-time
can live in poverty there's a thought
i trust joe biden and kamala harris to
guide us toward that better future
because i've seen up close their empathy
and their capacity just as i've seen my
fellow americans capacity
to support and include one another in
new ways
and do better by the promise of america
the day i was born the idea of an out
candidate
seeking any federal office at all was
laughable
yet earlier this year i campaigned for
the presidency
often with my husband chaston at my side
winning delegates to this
very convention now i come to this
convention
proudly supporting joe biden and kamala
harris
joining fellow democrats who were
squaring off in competition just a few
months ago
a number of us recently got together to
talk about the joe
we know
hi i'm cory booker welcome to everybody
at home
i am very excited to present to you a
group of people that ran
in the 2020 democratic primary against
joe biden
you can think of this sort of okay this
is this we're gonna
hold off until the next thing because i
do want to answer questions and say
thanks to people
ms chris descending fractal division
optimism and motor man have subscribed
with twitch prime which i really
appreciate
lefty lebowski asks the wife thinks
watching the rnc will cause
ibs is that fake news uh
i would not be i would be prepared for
every eventuality when it comes to the
rnc
i think it's going to be sick i think
it's going to be sick all right people
want to hear bernie let's listen
at night when i was giving one of those
floor speeches and corey you know what
this is like
no one was there no one was watching i
was all alone
and i gave my speech which much vigor
to a completely empty chamber and i
walked out of there and i thought i
wonder if my mom was even watching this
on c-span
and at that moment the cell phone rings
and i actually thought maybe my mom was
watching it
and you know who it was it was joe biden
and that kind of goes to not only his
kindness for calling me and being a
mentor but it also goes to how much he
cares about our government
and what people are saying and that even
when he's at home at night
he's watching and he cares but amy we
all want to know
did your mother watch the speech
you remember the step fry when when we
were waiting to go on
it worked out to where i was there the
same time he was
and he pulled me aside at one point and
he pointed to somebody who
we both knew who was working on my
campaign uh but he'd known from before
and let me know that that that was
somebody who'd gone through a family
tragedy
that that joe somehow knew about and
just thought it was important for me to
know that
uh about uh someone who was working with
me and i thought
you know over time i realized that that
was just basic to who he is but that
always stuck with me
elizabeth do you have any uh
remembrances as well
i think the day i saw joe the clearest
was on the one-year anniversary of the
boston marathon bombing
and everyone of course was enormously
honored to have the vice president
here but at some point in that speech
he shifted to the parent who had lost a
child
to the man who had lost a wife to
someone who had experienced
loss very personally
and he spoke to each of the families
from the heart that's phenomenal
i want to ask uh what gets you excited
about uh this
idea of the inclusion of big ideas
uh from all over the the party uh into
the future into the next administration
the the magic of joe biden
is that everything he does becomes the
new reasonable
if he comes with an ambitious plan to
address climate change
all of a sudden everyone's going to
follow his lead you can see it with him
choosing kamala too
he wants to build the best team let's do
it together that's how we're going to
rebuild this country
i'm so optimistic about our country
right now despite
some very dark days for a lot of our
fellow americans
in large part because of what young
people are doing right now
after the murder of ahmad arbury and
brianna taylor and
george floyd young people by and large
led these protests and they did so in
the absolute best traditions of this
country the tradition
of john lewis my optimism and
and my faith in this country is
reflected in
in those young people and the way that
joe
and kamala are listening to them and
incorporating their ideas
and their urgency into the campaign that
they're running and the administration
that they're going to lead
and i often think some people say they
don't know if they're going to vote or
vote or not
are saying that from a point of
privilege that a lot of americans don't
have
there are so many things for lots of
folks who live life
on the margins that this election is
going to decide and maybe it's not a
life or death issue for you
right uh but we are all in this together
absolutely
corey what i would say is that uh
this is clearly the most important
election
in the modern history of this country
and john you have
a human being who is empathetic
who is honest who is decent
and at this particular moment in
american history my god
that is something that this country
absolutely needs
right and all of us whether you're
progressives whether you're moderates or
conservatives
have got to come together to defeat this
president
together thanks for that bernie i want
to thank you all for joining us for this
segment
thank you i mean this sincerely it was
an honor to run against you
and it is even a greater honor to stand
with you
in support of joe biden and kamala
harris
oh boy mike bloomberg good evening
minnie i've never been much for partisan
politics
i've supported democrats republicans and
independents that brighton accident hell
i've actually been a democrat republican
and independent
all about people oh boy and the two
people running for president
couldn't be more different one believes
in facts
one does not right one listens to
experts
the other thinks he knows everything
true one looks forward and sees strength
in america's diversity
the other looks backwards and sees
immigrants as enemies
and white supremacists as allies yes
here's another difference one has proven
he knows how to handle a crisis
by helping to lead the economic
turnaround after the 2008 recession
while the other has not only failed to
lead he has made the current crisis much
worse
also bleach when confronted with the
biggest calamity any president has faced
in the modern era
donald trump spent the year downplaying
the threat
ignoring science and recommending quack
cures
which let covert 19 spread much faster
than it should have
leaving hundreds of thousands needlessly
sick or dead
he has failed the american people
catastrophically
four years ago i came before this very
convention and said
new yorkers know a khan when we see one
but tonight i'm not asking you to vote
against donald trump because he's a bad
guy
i'm urging you to vote against him
because he's done a bad job
right today unemployment is at historic
highs
and small businesses are struggling just
to survive
remember when warren quoted him calling
women horse-faced allegedly
i ran for mayor i spent 20 years running
a business i started from scratch
so i want to ask small business owners
and their employees one question
and it's a question for everyone would
you rehire
or work for someone who ran your
business into the ground
and who always does what's best for him
or her even when it hurts the company
and whose reckless decisions put you in
danger
and who spends more time tweeting than
working
if the answer is no why the hell would
we
ever rehire donald trump for another
four years
right trump says we should vote for him
because he's a great businessman
really he drove his companies into
bankruptcy six times
always leaving behind customers because
trump so triggered that bloomberg's way
richer than him
business with him well this time all of
us
are paying the price and we can't let
him get away with it again
donald says we should vote for him
because the economy was great before the
virus
huh biden and obama created more jobs
over their last three years than the
trump administration did over their
first three
and economic growth was higher under
biden and obama
than under trump in fact while biden
helped save one million
auto industry jobs trump has lost 250
000 manufacturing jobs so when trump
says
he wants to make america great again
he's making a pretty good
case for joe biden right look our goal
shouldn't be to bring back the pandemic
economy
it should be as joe says to build it
back better
joe's economic plan will create clean
energy jobs that help
fight another crisis that trump is
ignoring climate change
and joe will rebuild our crumbling roads
and bridges
something trump has incessantly talked
about doing
but in the last three three and a half
years he hasn't
done anything what a joke
and let me tell you a little secret
donald trump's economic plan
was to give a huge tax cut to guys like
me
who didn't need it and then lie about it
to everyone else
well joe will roll back that tax cut
that i got
so we can fund things our whole country
needs
like training for adults who have lost
jobs and making college more affordable
and investing in american research and
development
so that the products of tomorrow are
made today by american workers
you know growing up i was taught to
believe that america is the greatest
country in the world
not because we won the second world war
but because of why we fought it
for freedom democracy and equality
my favorite childhood book was called
johnny tremaine
about a boston boy who joins the sons of
liberty at the dawn of the american
revolution
at the end of the book johnny stands on
lexington
commons and sees a nation that is quote
green with spring dreaming of the future
that's the america i know and love and
that's the america we are in danger of
losing
under this president so let's put an end
to this whole sorry chapter in american
history
and elect leaders who will bring
integrity and stability
sanity and competence back to the white
house
joe and kamala go get them for all of us
right there's mike bloomberg
we can help you find the best and safest
way to vote in your state
simply text by the way here is my
favorite
uh bloomberg moment from the campaign
remember this guys
for another four years and we can't
stand that
so i like to talk about who we're
running against
a billionaire who calls women fat broads
and horse-faced lesbians and no i'm not
talking about donald trump
i'm talking about mayor bloomberg
just as good today oh my god it's so
good
it's so good it's just perfect it's
perfect
uh wow okay
thanks to the italian stallion that
one's so good
who has subscribed with prime and wrb
farley has subscribed as well
um i also want to say thank you to
um leslie yellow hammer
who is new member number 12 william tate
is number 13.
seth lichtenstein is number 14
lisa newman number 15 brian washburn
number 16.
that puts us at 16 uh website members
at joinpakman.com a lot of super chats
coming in
fuse coach says do twitch subs get the
bonus show
no they don't ren holder says say
say hi to my wife casey hi casey hope
you're doing well
neptune says i know people are
disappointed about biden but shouldn't
we be thankful bloomberg wasn't the
nominee it could always be worse that's
a fair point
sugar skull says bernie's the one that
creates change in the party
andrew mcmurray says you did not lol at
that be real david
mike in west palm beach i guess i have
to say
bloomy's speech was good adam bellow
says bloomberg's best work
all season scott hack says how is it
that bloomberg has given the best speech
it really wasn't bad i don't know that
it's the best but it really was not a
bad speech
um at all and you know whether he should
have been there at all is certainly a
question
conor brenner says hey david have you
seen seen tim pool's content in the last
six months
no it's as if he's operating in an
alternate universe it's oan level crap
the size of his following truly
frightens me worth a show
um yeah i just i haven't i just don't
know i'm too busy
rock creights says can you say hi to my
wife brittany yes
brittany kreutz hope you're doing well
eggo productions has also subscribed at
the soyboy level
and sovie pujols is new member number
17 today oh let's hear from the good
rabbi i'm interested now
shiva and towards the end of the service
the door opens up
and this person who was much younger
mods on alert by the way
the generations who were there walked in
the room it was our u.s senator
joe biden he was just very respectful
and he stayed in the back and his head
was bound in reverence
and at the end i said senator biden like
why are you here because how does a nice
irish catholic boy know from shiva
and what he said was just so lovely he
said this dear lady
gave 18 to my campaign from the very
first time i started in 1972
so he wanted to show his respects by
saying thank you
and that just blew me away
all right a beautiful message of peace
and love from the rabbi
great to hear um other messages coming
in
chef's pawn says the best part was that
wikipedia said he died that night
because of warren
uh okay people demanding to hear from
the granddaughters okay
um he's always eating ice cream
usually it's like vanilla vanilla
vanilla sprinkles
chocolate sprinkles vanilla vanilla is a
waste of an ice cream
flavor it's like nothing you know i
could give you 20 flavors better than
vanilla he likes ice cream in hidden
ways
yeah like eating it like in the freezer
so that's
my grandma he like hides it
how often does he call you like
everybody yeah
like if we don't talk to him for like a
day he'll ask what's wrong yeah he'll
think we're like
not a lot he always calls with the same
energy
even after he's just done 15 interviews
in a row
hi pop i was just talking about you i
don't necessarily pick up every day but
i have a lot of voicemails he will pick
up our calls no matter where he is
he'd be like on stage giving a speech
and we'd call him and he'd be like
what's wrong is everything good
like just going to check in what does
the word
family mean to you it's a lot of time
together it's like
we've we've grown up together he's made
sure that every single tradition
every holiday we're all together
i don't think that there's been any
decision no matter how big or small that
we haven't
decided as a family pop
told us that this election would be
totally different
from any other election ever he was
worried how
it would affect his kids whether or not
we wanted to go through another campaign
and be scrutinized by the press
there had been talks of a big meeting
coming it's
normally called by the parents i would
say but this time it was called by me
i came down from penn and maisie came up
from dc and my cousins lived down the
road
he thought we were calling a meeting
sort of to like discuss
you know whether or not we wanted him to
but really we were calling it to be like
get in that race hurry up we just
knew that he had to run and we weren't
going to take noah as an answer
at the end of the day i think we're all
very happy we had that meeting
all right well when you get back there
give me a call to tell me how the whole
thing went okay
okay i will i love you baby i love you
too
we want to ensure that our kids live in
a nation that is safe
happy healthy and fair all right so
building up now towards joe biden's
speech
likely just minutes away um yeah listen
guys vanilla as a flavor
it's not flavor it's just the base right
i mean think of you know
pistachio double chocolate chocolate
chunk
chocolate chip mint chocolate chip black
raspberry
um cookie dough um
mango okay sorbets
you understand what's going on here
right i mean it's like this is just this
is crazy
um
[Music]
coffee coffee ice cream yes exactly okay
please
oh my god everybody canceled their
memberships i should never mention ice
cream again
okay um stephen coast
says bloomberg can't even read properly
he believes not a word he says in that
speech he's desperate for relevance
wipo jefe says i'm voting in person to
take off a little stress from the post
office
ps black lives matter alison tomsky
sends a super chat ruben gonzalez says
david say hi to my wife
lil marat lily marez in spanish
hola and tell her to drop her cell phone
and pay attention
all in spanish tnx lol oh my i don't
know anything about that but
hola lily dave pratt
you not liking vanilla is the least
sensible thing i've ever heard you say
and i spent five bucks to make sure you
knew that
and dave gardner says what does america
have that canada does not
good neighbors please don't let the
sweaty incoherent mango in chief win
then you will be good neighbors
and on that note some great neighbors
for us on the stream michael phillips
today is new member number 18
and stephen carter is new member number
19.
uh let's see what the uh curries have to
say
you knew that joe biden was going to
have
a woman as his vice president
surprise and like happy why
there's like not
a lot of women health like
being president and helping alongside
the president
how important do you think your faith is
in the way that you live your life
really big because i'm grateful for all
the things
that i have and i love my family
and with that said everyone we really
thank you one for listening to this very
candid conversation
with our daughters and we just want to
encourage you
to truly do your research think about
your own homes and what you'd like to
see projected out into the world
in the right direction is making sure
that you vote this election for biden
[Music]
whatever you do please vote
right every vote counts just remember
that
you're gonna dance out
okay here's the big question
how much of your time and energy are you
willing to devote
to elect joe biden here's my answer
i'm going all in look elections can
break your heart
but sometimes they can make you sing
from the mountaintops
and this year we're gonna sing this year
we're going to elect a president who's
honest experienced
and intelligent a president who actually
believes in the rule of law
who will restore dignity and normalcy to
the white house
and the soul of this nation and boy
won't that be something one of my
favorite things joe biden says is that
you can succeed in life
without sacrificing your ideals or your
commitment to family
thanks for building here who better to
introduce our nominee
joe biden than his children
i'm hunter biden and i'm ashley biden
joe biden is our dad
and bo is our brother we want to tell
you what kind of president our dad will
be
he will be tough and honest caring
and principled he'll listen he'll be
there when you need him
he'll tell you the truth even when you
don't want to hear it
he'll never let you down he'll be rock
steady
the strongest shoulder you can ever lean
on
he'll beam with pride every time you
succeed
who'll make your grandkids feel that
what they've got to say
matters he'll treat everyone with
respect no matter who
you are he'll get up no matter how many
times he's been knocked down
he'll be the worst enemy any bully ever
saw
he'll be the best friend you've ever had
he'll love you with all of his heart
and if you give him your cell phone
number he's going to call it
how do we know because he's been that
way our whole
lives he's been a great father
and we think he'll be a great president
beau isn't with us any longer but he is
still
very much alive in our hearts and we can
still hear his strong voice
just like it was yesterday just like it
was yesterday
in 2008 and 2012 he introduced our dad
at those conventions
and if he was here we're pretty sure
we'd know
what he'd say so before we show you a
film about our dad's journey
we wanted to give bo the last word bo
bo take it away in moments both
public and private he's the father i've
always known
the grandfather my children love and
adore
my father my hero joe biden
[Music]
our lives have been turned upside down
shattered and shaken
but the american story has had moments
like this before
and he was there answering the call
when we came into office in 2009 we were
going through what was then the worst
financial and economic crisis
since the great depression
the economy was hemorrhaging hundreds of
thousands of jobs
a week people were losing their homes to
foreclosure
the financial system was in tatters auto
sales had dropped to
near zero levels the auto companies
faced
bankruptcy and many said let them
fail
but joe remembered his father and what
it meant to lose a job
the finnegans and bidens were irish
catholic
[Music]
joe was there first
[Music]
and then his sister valerie from the
moment i opened my eyes
my big brother was there
the thing that was most important was
family
and family and family
as the post-war boom faded joe's father
struggled to find work and scranton
but 140 miles south there was a job
cleaning boilers in wilmington there was
a long
stairway up to the second floor
dad went up to joey in our bedroom
and saying joey you got to be a big boy
for the first time joe saw the heavy
burden on a father
and it was a lesson he would never
forget
the job is a lot more than a paycheck is
about dignity
the country was losing tens of thousands
of jobs a day
and they needed three votes to pass the
economic rescue package
joe biden was handled the task of going
to get those three republican votes
joe returned to the place where he had
been so effective
passionate argument sympathetic
listening
willingness to make adjustments and
accommodations to bring people on board
when the law finally passed the
president tapped his partner
to run the program joe tracked every
dollar calling mayors
and governors talking to them on the
phone one on one
he gave all of them his cell phone and i
watched him bring his heart to that
job it matters that you have
in your mind the family that you're
trying to reach the neighborhood that
you're trying to reach the people
whose lives are affected by what you do
the skills that had made him
so effective had not come easy
when he entered school there was a
problem
joe had a stutter and it's mortifying
it allows that child to become an object
to ridicule
when his teacher mimicked him and joe
ran home from school
his mother drove him back did you say to
my son mr
bite the nun said i was just trying to
make a point
my mother stood up oh five foot two of
her if you ever talk to my son like that
again i'll come back and rip that damn
bonnet off your head do you understand
me
joey go back to class joe resolved to
overcome his stutter
some letters are harder than others and
i used to get up at night
and go stand in front of the mirror with
a flashlight and practice
she'd make me look her in the eye look
at me
remember joey you're the smartest boy in
that class
nobody's better than you joey
from having to deal with stuttering it
gave me insight into other people's pain
other people's suffering at 19 joe
sought out a summer job that
few of his peers considered taking he
was a lifeguard along with the black
lifeguards
that's when i first seen jail and we
became friends
it was one of the best things i've ever
done because it gave me a sense
that we really didn't know one of them
after martin luther king jr was
assassinated
riots broke out in wilmington and the
national guard stayed for almost a year
[Music]
i quit the law firm and asked for a job
to become a public defender
that's what sort of got me involved in
politics
j caleb boggs was a popular war hero in
a solidly republican state
and few took joe's campaign seriously in
delaware
the democratic party was non-functional
when it got time to put up a candidate
they didn't want to touch it this young
upstart
joe biden who had a lot of ideas and no
money
no influence the party said okay well
then go ahead
find give it a whirl that's all i can
actually look at you like you can see
help me out if not vote for the other
fellow and look me over
you know we'd have a coffee and we'd
come out of that we'd have five more
coffees
[Music]
he was very articulate on the issues he
brought people to say
not just that well i agree with what
you're doing is you know what can i do
to help
delaware is the first state j caleb
boggs who is the incumbent
republican being challenged by joseph
biden biden is a democrat who's 29 years
of age
but exhilaration soon turned to
it was clear he had decided that i'm not
going to be a senator
that the boys need me too much
i was prepared to walk away in 1973
with men like ted kennedy and mike
mansfield
you were at humphrey fritz hollings
danny in hallway
they convinced me to stay to stay six
months joe remember danny just stay six
months
he couldn't allow the suffering to
debilitate him just like he couldn't
allow the stuttering to define him
that's the backbone there's something
bigger than joe's suffering
the senate turned out to be a wonderful
place for him
he had a real gift for bringing people
together
[Music]
the three of them had a bond that was
forged in sorrow and expanded into joy
when
jill entered they had built this
beautiful
family this circle of trust
and then the extra gift of ashley
growing up it was full of adventure
laughter we do everything as a family
and we've always done everything as a
family he was
always a good loving father i mean
there's nothing more
important to joe than his children it's
hard to explain
how ever-present he was
in our lives you don't have to guess
what my dad believes
a great benefit of being my father is
that he doesn't have to contort himself
into different people at different times
beau was going to do fine things i mean
he had it all
and then he got sick
the whole world tilted and it felt like
we were all falling off
once again joe faced the unimaginable
my mother she said bravery resides in
every heart
and someday it will be summoned
the way he survived losing my mom and my
sister
and then losing my brother is
understanding that that you have to have
purpose
every day i get up i ask myself i hope
he's proud of me
because that's that makes me move on
[Music]
from his time in the senate and then the
white house
joe always found a way forward forging
unlikely friendships and alliances
and time after time he made progress
possible and always holding in his heart
the struggles of his family and every
family
always fighting to make his country
whole
it's a very rare quality to bring your
empathy skills to the process of
governing
joe biden never forgets that that's the
point
of moving the wheels of government he
will
keep his word he will reach out
and hear what other people have to say
to have somebody who believes in what's
best in us
somebody like joe biden who actually
believes in the american idea
that's the kind of person who i want in
the white house
[Music]
here we go
good evening ella baker
a giant of the civil rights movement
left us with this wisdom
give people light and they will find the
way
give people light those are words for
our time
the current president has cloaked
american darkness for much too long
too much anger too much fear too much
division
here and now i give you my word
if you entrust me with the presidency i
will draw on the best of us
not the worst i'll be an ally of the
light
not the darkness it's time for us
for we the people to come together
and make no mistake united we can and
will overcome this season of darkness in
america
we'll choose hope over fear facts over
fiction
fairness over privilege i'm a proud
democrat
and i'll be proud to carry the banner of
our party into the general election
so it's with great honor and humility i
accept this nomination for president of
the united states of america
but while i'll be a democratic candidate
i will be an american president
i'll work hard for those who didn't
support me as hard for
them as i did for those who did vote for
me
that's the job of a president to
represent
all of us not just our base or our party
this is not a partisan moment this must
be an american moment
it's the moment the calls for hope and
light and love
hope for our future light to see our way
forward
and love for one another america isn't
just a collection of
clashing interests of red states or blue
states
we're so much bigger than that we're so
much better than that
no nearly a century ago franklin
roosevelt
pledged a new deal in a time of massive
unemployment
uncertainty and fear stricken by a
disease stricken by a virus
fdr insisted that he would recover and
prevail and he believed
america could as well and he did and we
can as well
this campaign isn't just about winning
votes it's about winning the heart and
yes the soul of america
winning it for the generous among us not
the selfish
wanting it for workers to keep this
country going not just the privileged
few at the top
winning for those communities who have
known the injustice of a knee on the
neck
for all the young people have known only
america
being rising inequity and shrinking
opportunity
they deserve the experience of america's
promise
they deserve to experience it in full
you know no generation ever knows what
history will ask of it
all we can ever know is whether we're
ready
when that moment arrives and now history
has delivered us
to one of the most difficult moments
america has ever faced
four four historic crises all at the
same time
a perfect storm the worst pandemic in
over a hundred years
the worst economic crisis since the
great depression
the most compelling call for racial
justice since the 60s
and the undeniable realities and
ex and just the accelerating threats of
climate change
so the question for us is simple are we
ready
i believe we are we must be
you know all elections important we know
in our bones this one is more
consequential
as many have said america is at an
inflection point
a time of real peril but also
extraordinary possibilities
we can choose a path of becoming angrier
less hopeful
more divided a path of shadow and
suspicion
or or we can choose a different path and
together
take this chance to heal to reform to
unite
a path of hope and light this is a
life-changing election
this will determine what america is
going to look like for a long long time
character is on the ballot compassion is
on the ballot
decency science democracy they're
all on the ballot who we are as a nation
what we stand for most importantly who
we want to be
that's all on the ballot and the choice
could not be more clear
no rhetoric is needed just judge this
president
on the facts five million americans
infected by covet 19.
more than 170 000 americans have died
by far the worst performance of any
nation on earth
more than 50 million people have filed
for unemployment this year
more than 10 million people are going to
lose their health insurance this year
nearly one in six small businesses have
closed this year
and this president if he's reelected
you know what will happen cases and
deaths will remain far
too high more mom-and-pop businesses
will close their doors
and this time for good all true working
families will struggle to get by
and yet the wealthiest one percent will
get
tens of billions of dollars in new tax
breaks
and the assault on the affordable care
act will continue until it's destroyed
taking insurance away from more than 20
million people
including more than 15 million people on
medicaid
and getting rid of the protections that
president obama worked so hard to get
past
for people who have the hundred million
more people who have pre-existing
conditions
and speaking of president obama a man i
was honored to serve alongside
for eight years as vice president let me
take this moment to say something we
don't say nearly enough
thank you mr president you were a great
president
a president of our children could and
did look up to
one's going to say that about the
current occupant of the white house
what we know about this president is if
he's given four more years
he'll be what he's been for the last
four years worse
the president takes no responsibility
refuses to lead
blames others cozies up to dictators and
fans the flames of hate and division
he'll wake up every day believing the
job is all about him
never about you is that the american you
want
for you your family your children
i see a different america one that's
generous and strong
selfless and humble it's an american we
can rebuild together
as president the first step i will take
we to get control of the virus that has
ruined
so many lives because i understand
something this president hasn't from the
beginning
going into policy now never get our
economy back on track
we will never get our kids safely back
in schools
we'll never have our lives back until we
deal with this virus
the tragedy of where we are today is it
didn't
have to be this bad just look around
it's not this bad in canada or europe or
japan
or almost anywhere else in the world
true
and the president keeps telling us the
virus is going to disappear he keeps
waiting for a miracle
well i have news for him no miracle is
coming
we lead the world and confirm cases lead
the world in deaths
are economies in tatters with black
latino asian american native american
communities
bearing the brunt of it and after all
this time
the president still does not have a plan
well i do if i'm your president on day
one
we'll implement the national strategy
i've been laying out since
march we'll develop
and deploy rapid tests with results
available immediately we'll make the
medical supplies and protective
equipment that our country needs
and we'll make them here in america so
we will never again
be at the mercy of china or other
foreign countries in order to protect
our own people we'll make sure our
schools
have the resources they need to be open
safe and effective we'll put politics
aside
we'll take the muzzle off our experts so
the public gets the information
they need and deserve honest unvarnished
truth
they can handle it
we'll have a national mandate to wear a
mask not as a burden but as a patriotic
duty to protect one another uh-oh people
are going to be triggered by this short
we'll do what we should have done from
the very beginning
our current president has failed in his
most basic duty to the nation
this is a good approach because
coronavirus ranks as the most important
issue for voters and it's one of trump's
lowest
in terms of approval that is
unforgivable
as president i'll make you a promise
i'll protect america
i will defend us from every attack seen
and unseen
always without exception every time
look i understand i understand how hard
it is to have any hope right now
on this summer night let me take a
moment to speak to those of you who have
lost the most i have some idea how it
feels to lose someone you love
i know that deep black hole that opens
up in the middle of your chest and you
feel like you're being sucked into it
i know how mean and cruel and unfair
life can be sometimes but i've learned
two things
first your loved one may have left this
earth
but they'll never leave your heart
they'll always be with you you'll always
hear them
and second i found the best way through
pain
and laws and grief is to find purpose
as god's children each of us have a
purpose over in our lives
we have a great purpose as a nation
to open the doors of opportunity to all
americans
to save our democracy to be a light to
the world once again
and finally to live up to and make real
the words written in the sacred
documents that founded this nation
that all men and women are created equal
endowed by their creator with certain
inalienable rights among them
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
you know my dad was an honorable decent
man
he got knocked down a few times pretty
hard trump is
hoping for an implosion or very very
upset right now
and he built a great middle class life
for our family
he used to say joey i don't expect the
government to solve my problems but i
sure in hell expect them to understand
them
and then he'd say joey a job is about a
lot more than a paycheck
it's about your dignity it's about
respect
it's about your place in the community
it's about being able to get your kid in
the eye and say honey
it's gonna be okay and mean it
i've never forgotten those lessons
that's why my economic plan is all about
jobs
dignity respect and community
together we can and will rebuild our
economy
and when we do we'll not only build back
we'll build back better
with modern roads bridges highways
broadband
ports and airports as a new foundation
for economic growth
with pipes that transport clean water
to every community with five million new
manufacturing and technology jobs
so the future is made in america talking
about water not about the flak the fact
that his toilet won't flush which is the
way trump talks about water
prices by building on the affordable
care act he's trying to rip away
with an education system that trains our
people for the best jobs of the 21st
century there's not a single thing
american workers can't do and where cost
doesn't prevent young people from going
to college
and student debt doesn't crush them when
they get out
with the child care and elder care
system that makes it possible for
parents to
go to work and for the elderly to stay
in their homes with
dignity with an immigration system
that powers our economy and reflects our
values
and with newly empowered labor unions
they're the ones that built the middle
class
with equal pay for women with rising
wages
you can raise a child on a family on
and yes we're going to do more than
praise our essential workers
we're finally going to pay them pay them
we can and we will deal with climate
change
it's not only a crisis it's an enormous
opportunity
an opportunity for america to lead the
world in clean energy
and create millions of new good paying
jobs
in the process and we can pay for these
investments
by ending loopholes unnecessary
loopholes and the president's 1.3
trillion dollar tax giveaway
to the wealthiest one percent and the
biggest most profitable corporations
some of which do not pay any tax at all
because we don't need a tax code that
rewards wealth
more than it rewards work
i'm not looking to punish anyone far
from it
but it's long past time the wealthiest
people
and the biggest corporations in this
country paid their fair share
and for our seniors social security
is a sacred obligation a sacred
promise made they paid for
the current president is threatening to
break that promise
he's proposing to eliminate a tax that
pays for almost
half the social security without any way
of making up for that lost revenue
resulting in cuts i will not let that
happen
if i'm your president we're going to
protect social security
and medicare you have my word
one of the most powerful voices we hear
in the country today
is from our young people they're
speaking to the inequity and injustice
that has grown up in america
economic injustice racial injustice
environmental injustice i hear their
voices if you listen you can hear them
too
and whether it's the accidental
existential threat posed by climate
change
the daily fear of being gunned down in
school
or the inability to get started in your
first job
will be the work of the next president
to restore the promise
of america to everyone
and i'm not gonna have to do it alone
because i'll have a great vice president
at my side
senator kamala harris she's a powerful
voice for this nation
her story is the american story
she knows about all the obstacles thrown
in the way of so many in our country
women black women black americans
south asian americans immigrants the
left out and the left behind
but she's overcome every obstacle she's
ever faced
no one's been tougher on the big banks
than a gun on the gun lobby
no one's been tougher in calling out the
current administration for its extremism
it's failure to follow the law it's
failure to simply
tell the truth
kamal and i both draw from our families
that's where we get our strength for
kamala it's doug
and their families for me it's jill and
ours
i've said many times no man deserves one
great love in his life let alone two
but i've known two after losing my first
wife in that car accident
jill came into my life she put our
family back together
she's an educator a mom a military mom
and an unstoppable force if she puts her
mind to it
just get out of the way she's going to
get it done
she was a great second lady and i know
she'll make a great first lady for this
nation
she loves this country so much
and i'll always have the strength that
can only come from family
hunter ashley all our grandchildren
my brothers my sister they give me
courage they lift me up
while he's no longer with us
bo inspires me every day
both served our nation in uniform a year
in iraq a decorated
iraqi war veteran so i take very
personally
and i the profound responsibility of
serving as commander-in-chief
i'll be a president who will stand with
our allies and friends and make it clear
to our adversaries
the days of cozying up to dictators is
over
under president biden america will not
turn a blind eye to russian bounties on
the heads of american soldiers
beautiful no light put up with foreign
interference on our most
sacred democratic exercise voting right
and i'll always stand for our values
of human rights and dignity a working
common purpose
for a more secure peaceful and
prosperous world
i would rap history
history has thrust one more urgent task
on us
will we be the generation that
finally wipes out the stain of racism
from our national character
i believe we're up to it i believe we're
ready
just a week ago yesterday was the third
anniversary of the events in
charlottesville
close your eyes remember what you saw on
television remember seeing
those neo-nazis and klansmen and white
supremacists
coming out of fields with lighted
torches
veins bulging spewing the same same
anti-semitic bile
hurt across europe in the 30s sick
remember the violent clash that ensued
between those spreading hate
and those with the courage to stand
against it
and remember what the president said
when asked
he said there were quote very fine
people on both sides
it was a wake-up call for us as a
country and for me
a call to action at that moment i knew
i'd have to run
because my father taught us that silence
was complicity and i could never remain
silent or complicit at the time
i said we're in the battle for the soul
of this nation
and we are you know
one of the most important conversations
i've had this entire campaign
it was something this was someone who
was much too young to vote
i met with six-year-old gianna floyd the
day before her daddy
george floyd was laid to rest she's an
incredibly brave little girl and i'll
never forget it when i leaned down
to speak to her she looked in my eyes
and she said i quote
daddy changed the world
daddy changed the world
her words burrowed deep into my heart
maybe george floyd murder was a breaking
point
maybe john lewis is passing the
inspiration
but however has come to be however it's
happened
america's ready in john's words to lay
down quote the heavy burden of
hate at last
and to end the hard work
of rooting out our systemic racism
you know american history tells us that
it's been on our darkest moments
that we've made our greatest progress
that we found the light and this dark
moment
i believe we're poised to make great
progress again
that we can find the light once more
you know many people have heard me say
this but i've always believed you can
define america in one word
possibilities to defining feature
america
everything is possible
that in america everyone and i mean
everyone
should be given an opportunity to go as
far as their dreams and god-given
ability will take them
we can never lose that in times as
challenging as these
i believe there's only one way forward
as a united america a united america
united in our pursuit of a more perfect
union
united in our dreams of a better future
for us and for our children united in
our determination
to make the coming years bright
are you ready i believe we are
this is a great nation we're a good and
decent people
for lord's sake this is the united
states of america
and there's never been anything we've
been able to accomplish when we've done
it together
the irish poet sheamus heaney once wrote
history says don't hope on this side of
the grave
but then once in a lifetime
the longed for tidal wave of justice can
rise up
and hope and history rhyme
this is our moment to make hope and
history rhyme
with passion and purpose let us begin
you and i together
one nation under god unite our love for
america united in our love for each
other
for love is more powerful than hate hope
is more powerful than fear
and light is more powerful and dark this
is our moment
this is our mission may history be able
to say
that the end of this chapter of american
darkness began here
tonight as love and hope and light
join in the battle for the soul of the
nation
and this is a battle we will win and
we'll do it together
i promise you thank you and may god
bless you
and may god protect our troops
very good speech i must say
you know not pretending to be the most
progressive guy in the world and he's
not and that's not what this was about
but uh did what he had to do the
trumpists expecting an implosion
they're gonna be relegated to trump
tweeting in all caps more than likely
within a few minutes
i think it was well done well done did
what he had to do is what matters
[Music]
now it is going to be a shift with the
rnc next week
you know that st louis couple who waved
guns at protesters is going to be
speaking so it is going to be a
different
sort of thing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now
[Music]
driving
[Applause]
but people want me to check in with
[Music]
destiny
all right let's see what's up with
destiny we're really i'm really only
going to do five minutes because i do
have to get to bed because pog champ
starts tomorrow
um so uh
we're not going to do too too much but i
do want to see what's going on we are
going to do too too much
welcome to the 60 minute i'm so excited
guys i've got d-pack on stream for 60
minutes now
talk about that what's up how's it going
david deepak
pacman from twitch.tv so what do you
what did you think
um i mean i mean like this probably did
what it was supposed to do all the
[ __ ] and everything that was my god yeah
i don't think i was over the intention
for something like this but um i thought
that the last i feel like the
if i can remember i feel like the last
two nights were markedly better than the
first two except for on the third night
when it was like every state going
through this [ __ ] but that was boring to
me but
a lot of americans probably like to see
that [ __ ] to say their state or whatever
yeah that was
um it was certainly boring but i you
know part of part of the entire thing
i mean it's like listen if you were
hoping for the most progressive speech
ever
uh with the with bernie rhetoric it's
like no of course you weren't going to
get that but the point was
you know half of trumpists were
expecting biden to be
barely able to put a sentence together
obviously that
did not pan out for them and he hit
coronavirus which is the most important
issue for voters according to polls he
hid economy
he sounded like a normal person he seems
to have a normal relationship with his
family it's like he's everything trump's
not that's it
yeah basically yeah i oh sorry you
brought up the other the
the leftist stuff i'm trying i've been
trying so hard over the past few months
to get away from [ __ ] twitter
politics because it
drives me crazy yeah but one of the
things that a lot of people might chat
and then on twitter and then other
people on like the leftover mad about is
that like they didn't talk about
healthcare more
um you can tell me if you i think it
might take is crazy or whatever but like
i think right now i don't think the
average american carries
about like a public option or whatever
healthcare debate i think most people
just want the economy to get back to
normal so they can get back to work and
not have to worry about like
schools getting shut down or work
getting shut down our business is
getting shut down because of chronovirus
i think that's like
the number one like far and away issue
on most american minds right now yeah
i mean so the if this is not a trivial
difference between what joe biden wants
to do and what bernie sanders wanted to
do
you're sure of course but the three most
important issues according to voters
right now
are the virus the economy and race
relations that's like 60 65
i don't remember the exact number so you
want to focus on what are voting issues
and you want to focus
i think people know with trump's plan 30
million people lose health insurance
with biden's more people get it it's not
bernie's plan
but it's not a top three issue acutely
right now and so i think he did the
right thing
yeah and i i think like people will care
about like
the plans and [ __ ] when they roll out
but i just i don't think right now
i don't think that like that the concern
is like nuance to like
policy debate on the healthcare plans
yeah it's not
good this is a you this is like you have
to tell a story
where you're closing out the fourth day
with a story about why
all of the stuff built up to biden as
opposed to trump
for biden to go in and say we're gonna
you know the pub here's how the public
option is going to work and all of this
stuff
it's just not the right place for it i'm
not saying it's not important obviously
it's hugely important but it's just not
the speech for it
yeah for sure all right
so i got pog champs tomorrow i i might
be getting crushed
oh man by who it's hafu
oh yeah you haven't played her yet i
haven't played anybody tomorrow it
starts
man i'd be so i'd be really worried if i
was you yeah
no i am i am which is why uh you know
i'm gonna
i'm gonna sleep i plan i've got about 20
hours left until the match i plan to
sleep for 16 of them just to be super
well rested
wow that's really smart yes getting 16
hours of sleep yep yep yep yep
so by are you playing a game while we
talk right now
um yeah it's called factorio why i know
i just
it's uh interesting how you can do both
at once why do you have my stream up
why are you doing my stream up while
you're talking to me right now yeah i'm
stream sniping
oh is that what you're doing yeah
that's the case what did you think
overall i guess of everything
i mean i just think the format sucks the
format is going to make a lot of stuff
that would be pretty
okay with a crowd just very
cringe-worthy
so i mean i'm curious to see what
republicans do with it next week i mean
like the thing is
you know it's like next week the saint
louis couple who brandished firearms at
protests it's gonna be
good you know it's just it's a [ __ ] show
that's
the republicans will probably love it
right they may yeah but
you know one of the covington kids i
just don't know that right now
you know most people are decided so if
the idea is there's a slice of the
electorate that maybe hasn't decided or
isn't sure if they're voting
i don't know if the gun brandishing
couple is what gets people out to the
vote
well i've heard that like for most of
politics
especially like big elections it's not
really about like turning voters it's
just about turning out your base
right yeah i mean maybe it'll work for
that
yeah all right my friend listen it
sounds like you're about to go on a raid
or something so i'm going to let you get
back to it
um i don't know if you're about to tap
someone's mana or anything
like that but it seems like this is
quite quite a game you've got going here
so
you know i uh it's a it's a thing but
let's see how the rnc goes next week
yeah for sure um i hate to say it but
man i hope that's i feel like it's going
to be really entertaining
i know well the thing is the rnc is
going to be more fun than the than the
dnc it's going to be
you know more evidence of the downfall
of humanity but it'll be more fun
yeah yeah yeah it should be interesting
all right well good luck and uh poger's
champs
and um yeah i hope you get that 16 hours
of sleep all right stephen we'll talk to
you
all right i'll see you later okay we'll
see ya there's kenny two
kenny two as i know him uh so the some
people know him as the second
i call him kenny too all right everybody
in all seriousness i do want to do a day
of
strong day of prep tomorrow for pog
champs so i'm going to run
uh the fireworks are beautiful but once
you've seen one firework you've seen
them all
and we'll talk to everybody tomorrow
you